[Music]
in hard work pays off new what is over
that he's Jason Chen I'm Jason Chen
submitted by a gofer woke oh yeah call
for welcome are you woke like do know
about the world right now
I totally do woke this generous boss
sends his employees on exotic vacations
and give them free cars that's not like
he's trying to [ __ ] them whoo-hoo-hoo
how old is he and it is a female that
he's taking out on these free vacations
and does he mind if it's a male all
right I'm gonna throw it JK and I'm
gonna work for this guy yes wait what
you're gonna lose take me when you're
the boss
yep because you can't take care of me
better than I can take care of my make
every [ __ ] and quit your old company
brother what us you guys could survive
give them cars general oh I know why are
you give us cars what the hell I do only
one of those like tiny little toy cars
it makes two thanks Joe they do I just
know how but indirectly I do okay okay
all right so this guy his name is
radomir Katan and he is a successful
businessman from Montenegro what that is
not a real place where is that best
Europe's it's in the Box Balkan you said
get up are you sure about that
that should've been like a quick
question because I'm pretty sure we got
it wrong yeah I do like in South America
yeah Montenegro especially because I
said it better with the Latin yeah
Montenegro I thought I wasn't ask him
some reason black mountain-- you hope
the negro
yeah oh so he's a European dude yes
Eastern European standard so you know he
likes a musky ask alone his favorite
Cologne is trapar nor all of us -
where's tracks I know
why he's giving away free [ __ ] cars
he's Eastern European he owned a couple
parking lots and that's what he's doing
right now
oh that's what I'm investing for he owns
a tow truck company are he owns gas
stations run carwash brah
can't you guys just accept that this is
a good man ya know I always saw you was
good from the start that's why I said
I'm going to work for him the section
not for the car
good man but I also know that he smells
like cigarette and musky Cologne
okay well and probably has he unzips is
quite in shirt this much white shirt as
a [ __ ] coma then that's a jacket yeah
I am going to make a [ __ ] t-shirt
with his Jesus I own a few a t-shirt
with a [ __ ] wasn't loud I'm talking
about oh he said he the hostess I didn't
say too sure I say a shirt there's a
difference it could have been a problem
the blue line that has a zipper banging
my god oh you're gonna have it zipped
out of here hairy chest with this
[ __ ] hair busting out like I'm like
as I was fiction I like white [ __ ]
t-shirt that's the [ __ ] is it worth good
we would have it look like I did a
picture yes yes no happy funny if it's
exactly how we describe what an Asian do
you got smokin I got long he is slightly
overweight wrong time I think it a
little bit but that like fat buff like
like like body yeah big body can I guess
to slightly balding him and he he may or
may not wear glasses
depends on what his mood is in Pacific
they are glasses there's those big
square one with like a with like a gold
brim sweet oh oh he has a couple of
sunspots on the neck let's do this I
give up just I think you well first of
all you guys want to know what he does I
I already know we're good he gives cars
parking Mart car wash or he smuggles
Cologne it's none of them he all she
heard her men couch another Leone fianza
largest sporting goods store team big 6o
gonna be some big fix
it's a con sport all kakan sports
I heard of it I hope I'm pronouncing
exactly what I just said
this is what it look like pretty darn
good
Bobby you kind of good you got where
your track suit though ha ha ha is like
uh on the contrary proof Oh recently got
into politics so this is like his
political photo oh so see that so you
would have been other watches political
photo which is telling everyday photo
Adidas tracksuit yeah or cuma next moto
I'm going to show you our villa is the
photo of the four employees I received
cards from him after like you would get
more of them in card one you know me
that's a lot no but let me hear me up so
he rewards his most hardworking
employees and the most loyal Oh like
rewarding not just these four employees
like other employees so he sees that
they deserve certain things absolutely
cool over here the pretty one
so these are the four employees that
that looks like the Russian mob or
something yeah why does it look like a
Russian mop of 2004 yeah it's like
undercover actually yeah the track
jacket know that he's wearing all the
feet that's what I forgot motorcycle
jackets and racing jacket
yep OD in the center yes he's pretty
tall dude huh yeah so he surprised them
I was a blue and like they were they
were like crying and Richards like I
can't believe this
I can't believe this happen an Audi
surprise VW so he gave to VW Golf 6 and
2 VW Polo we don't know what those are
to the Europeans yeah they're not it
could be different ones the Gulf is of
with paid insurance
so cool we do me that's a punch buggy
right she's got a bunch of punch buddies
not the golfing the golf is their
hatchback Jenna useful besides I don't
see no de and Honda Accord even though
you mister not Toyota so really hold on
us Toyota's are like Yuri sir like it's
not a pristine yah-ha-ha patio de so
this other employee this employee here
so he found out that here he looks
pretty miserable in that the Jews he
wasn't even out even though the cars
away
no no secretary use like enjoy give him
cars his hairline is like [ __ ] took
out from Sesame Street
he's like the cow from says me 101 grand
prize to cool rewards for a good employ
oh yeah so if this one is really sweet
so he found out that this employee was
saving all of his paychecks to be able
to go to Brazil to see the World Cup and
so when he found out about that he
decided to take him himself with his own
money
and I give him a paid trip oh my god
this guy's amazing
yeah I was like a saint and in this one
is just him hanging out with his friend
no zipper skills damn look at that
[ __ ] turtleneck suppose he also gifted
that ones like that heavy do anyone do
this more fabric around his neck to his
body like what oh yeah you look he's a
penguin guy from a collection together
he got him oh yeah that's just please
oh we we make fun of it cuz we had a
great life he also were so jealous right
now
I go haters yeah so a couple of years
ago he also sent a group of 14 employees
on an exotic vacation to the Bahamas and
also to the gazelle so it's like another
group damn shows else so yeah black
singer
[Music]
welcome to jazz night my name is Giselle
you saying that he sent them there
simply because they deserved it that's
so Jen
determine oh how you deserve it like in
a company like what's his level because
everybody you know some people are hella
generous and it's kind of like you do
all the bare minimum in this life you
deserve it and some people are just
[ __ ] dick faces so you have to do
some superhuman [ __ ] - deserve it I just
want to know what his standards are yeah
I want to know - because they also sent
them on a luxury yeah cuz I'll quit
right [ __ ] now if you know can't quit
you can quit your old come can't quit
something you created [ __ ] i'm trapped
forever i just want to sell tennis
rackets and freakin soccer balls in
Moldova Montenegro yes Europe um so
listen I wanted to tell you guys one of
his coat of his because I thought it was
really nice so keep that so when he was
being asked like why don't you just go
like you cheaper means to reward rooms
[ __ ] you can't do that bonuses or
small raise I don't believe it out
[ __ ] this is what he said
money comes and goes when memories are
forever I have a friend who runs their
travel agency and I asked him what's on
offer and the prices because I wanted to
offer my employee vacation when they
returned they were happier and worked
even harder they showed me photographs
and we left together at their adventures
that's a freaking good leader man yeah
that isn't I just you know that for a
fact
he's making so much money but he could
do this yeah but I'd love to have money
that wouldn't do that that's what I'm
saying I want to know how much money his
company is making I don't know I mean
like if if you look at it on a bigger
scale of things it's really not that
much to send a handful of employees we
do it every year that's right and we
probably don't make any more goes to
what do you guys make so what Josie the
same hey I'm a [ __ ] good boss I know
so you're saying you're gonna leave us
I'm like no you are this bus
or to Quadro I don't want to do this
anymore
imagine smiling it is here come round at
this time somewhat I have reproduce what
did I get myself into
oh [ __ ] funny hey guys would you
think of that video I know you loved it
so make sure to hit that like button to
watch more videos check it out up here
[Music]
[Music]